الروسيه سهله هذه المره تحديدا المنتجات
البترونيه الروسيه قطع القرار الحظر سقفا
اقصى قدره 100 دولار لسعر برميل المنتجات
النفطيه الروسيه الممتازه كالديزل اما
المنتجات البتروليه الروسيه الاقل جوده
كزيت الوقود فتحدد سقف فتحدد سقف سعرها
بخمسه واربعين دولارا للبرميل ياتي هذا
القرار بعد شهرين من اتفاق دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي ومجموعه السبع واستراليا على
تحديد سقف لسعر النفط الخام الروسي لا
يتجاوز 60 دولارا للبرميل وتستعد الاسواق
الاوروبيه لما وصفه مختصون في قطاع الطاقه
بفوضى فبراير مع دخول حظر الديزل الروسي
المنقول بحرا حيث تنفيذ اذ تعتمد كثيرا من
القطاعات الحيويه في اوروبا على هذا
المنتج الروسي
معنا الان اذا من بروكسل بيتر كاليبي
الكاتب المختص في الشؤون الاوروبيه ورئيس
تحرير موقع بروسلز ريبورت ومن موسكو
المحلل السياسي في غينيروف ارحب بكم
كيف تتفاعل موسكو مع هذا القرار الغربي
الجديد
تحيه لكم ولساده المشاهدين ولديتكم الكريم
موسكو تتعامل مع هذا القرار الاخير الذي
اتخذه الاتحاد الاوروبي فيما يتعلق بالنفط
المقرر بهدوء تام لان يبدو ان روسيا كانت
مستعده لمثل هذا التحول وهو ياتي قرارا
منطقيا بعد فازر حظر منذ شهرين على النفط
الروسي الخام وبالتالي لا جديده في هذا
القرار روسيا منعت يعني توريد او تصدير
النفط المقرر الى تلك الدول التي ايدت هذا
القرار وهناك سؤال فقط يتعلق
بتوريده الى اليابان التي يعني كانت قد
عيدت بشكل او شكليا هذا القرار ولكنها
خارج اطار تلك الدول التي تشترك في فرض
هذه العقوبات او هذا
على موسكو ونفسه شيء ينطبق على بلغاريا
بالنسبه لدول الاخرى قرار واحد قرار صارم
وهو فرض
عقوبات جوابيه يمكن تسميتها هكذا لانه
يعني يعتبر جوابا منطقيا تماما ردا على
تلك العقوبات التي فرضت على موسكو هناك
ايضا فرضيه اخرى ربما ستلجا اليها روسيا
في ردها على هذه
على هذا السقف السعري وهو ربما التحديد او
حتى منع توريد الوقود النووي الى دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي التي مازال الجزء الكبير
منها تعتمد على الوقود الروسي في هذا
القطاع الحساس ولكن بالنسبه للاوروبيين
والغرب عموما حينما يتخذون هذا القرار الى
اي حد الاوروبيون انفسهم متضررون بحكم ان
روسيا يمكنها ان تجد بدائل اس بديله
لنفطها او مشتقه بضائعها من المشتقات
البترونيه
[موسيقى]
التي قامت
بتشكيل هذا الحظر يعرفون
ان النفط الروسي سيجد طريقه الى الغرب على
ايه حال هنالك دول الى شرق عفوا مثلا الى
الهند
وتركيا والمغرب بالتالي تم فرض هذا الحذر
وفكره محاوله استهداف
مداخيل الى روسيا اذا ما نظرنا الى سعر
الديزل مثلا وهذا هو العنصر الاهم في هذا
القرار لان المستهدف بشكل اساسي هو لتيزل
الذي ياتي من روسيا الى اوروبا اذا ما
نظرنا الى سعر الديزل هذا السعر الان قد
تم تقليله لكنه قد يكون نتيجه انه قبل
الحظر فان المشترين الاوروبيين بداوا
بشراء كبيره من الديزل علينا ان ننتظر
ونرى كيف ان الاسعار مستقبلا سوف تتغير
لكن في حالتي
اذا ما كان هنالك
فرض لمسارات غير منطقيه للمنتجات النفطيه
الروسيه بالتالي اكيد هذا الامر سيؤدي الى
رفع اسعار المنتجات النفطيه بالنسبه
للمستهل عن جد وهذه الخطوه اذا كانت الدول
الغربيه او الدول الاوروبيه تعرف بان
روسيا
تتصرف بهذا الملف بشكل جيد ايضا روسيا
تعاملت مع الملف بشكل هادئ لانها متحضره
في الاساس له فما الجدوى من هذه الخطوه له
روسيا ستعاني اقتصاديا من هذه الخطوات لكن
هذا ليس الاساس الاساس هذه الخطوات
والعقوبات
محاوله لاقناع بوتا لايقاف اعتدائه الى
اوكرانيا على اوكرانيا وعلينا ان نكون
صريحين ان هذه العقوبات لم تكن فعاله من
اجل تحقيق هذا الهدف لا يبدو وكانها تؤثر
على قرار رئيس بوتين من الجانب الاخر فان
دفعات الاسلحه وشحنات الاسلحه لاوكرانيا
كانت مفيده جدا لاوكرانيا اذا من جهه فان
الغرب وحلفائه يحتاجون ان يفكروا هل من
الحكمه الاستمرار بفرض هذه العقوبات
بالاخذ بنظر الاعتبار النتيجه النهائيه
انها في حقيقتنا لم تحقق اهدافها
يعني روسيا حتى وان وجدت بدائل واسواق
بديله سواء في الشرق او في المغرب كما
انقرض ضيفنا قبل قليل ود اخرى الهند وغير
ذلك ولكن او ربما لجات الى السوق السوداء
يبقى في نهايه المطاف انا عائدات الروسيه
التي كانت منتظمه وبشكل كبير ستصبح محدوده
الى اي احد بالتالي هذا سيجبر الرئيس
بوتين على تغيير نهجه في التعامل مع الحرب
في اوكرانيا
انا لا اعتقد بان مثل هذه الاجراءات ستغير
خط الرئيس الروسي فيما يتعلق بالعمليه
العسكريه الخاصه كما تسميها روسيا
اوكرانيا ولا اعتقد بان حتى اي اجراءات
اخرى والحزمه العاشره مثلا من العقوبات
التي يعدها الاتحاد الاوروبي سوف تغير خطه
الرئيس الروسي فيما يتعلق بالتعامل مع هذه
العمليه لانه عازم كل العزم على المضي
قدما في الوصول بهذه العمليه الى نهايتها
المظفره وربما تحقيق اهدافها من خلال هذه
العمليه خلال وقت قريب لكن مع ذلك طبعا
بالنسبه لروسيا امور اخرى لابد من الافضل
النظر اليها لان هذه العقوبات ستؤثر مثلا
على او سوف تجبر روسيا على تقليص الانتاج
محلي من ليس فقط النفط الخام وانما تقليص
تاج المصافي
النفطيه وهذا ربما سوف يؤثر على الاسواق
الداخليه وبالتالي هناك خطط لا شك ان
وزاره
الطاقه وزاره الماليه تفكر فيها الان
لتجنب مثل هذا الشمال شكرا جزيلا لك من
موسكو المحل السياسيه
فيديروف وايضا نشكر من بروكسل بيتر كاليبي
الكاتب المختص في الشؤون الاوروبيه ورئيس
تحرير موقع